this is Rudy Huffman and what you're
seeing is a 30 watt six-round flying
through his brain curve this real
satisfaction I want you to keep this
sight in mind through the rest of the
video and if you do enjoy what you see
remember to like the video and subscribe
to see more
now sniper elite 4 is a game that
rewards precision with gratuitous
violence it asks players to patiently
wait for that perfect moment with the
target in the crosshair aligned then
revel in the satisfaction of making that
organ rupturing bone shattering kill
shot it's hugely satisfying and I enjoy
doing it over and over and over but
after a while I found myself hesitating
to pull the trigger and it was for a
reason that surprised me Sniper Elite
Force tagging system is used to gather
information on your prey and the most
basic it reveals the targets rank
inventory and weapons however tagging
someone can sometimes also display
allies Intel about a soldier this
information could be something about
their personality a relationship with
another soldier or an action from their
past in most video games involve sniping
your hundreds of meters away and this
separation creates a disconnect between
you and your target however sniper elite
force allied Intel bridges the gap and
humanizes the enemy somehow these
tidbits of information make each virtual
soldier feel real and your decision
whether to kill them will spare them
carry more weight from a distance is
easy to see enemies as targets in a
shooting gallery traveling back and
forth along a predetermined path however
for me the Allied in telling you them
with a personality they could be a
simple officer who keeps a photo of
their German Shepherd close to heart or
a cold-blooded killer who murdered a
poor 15 year old boy
obviously the argument exists that
soldiers are just doing their sworn duty
and following their orders just as
protagonist Carl Fairburn is when he
indiscriminately eliminates them but
gang an inside look at the men the game
designates as enemies injects a dose of
morality into the experience and for a
game sold in the back of rupturing
testicles piercing lungs and crushing
skulls with high-velocity bullets that
comes as a welcome surprise discovering
this hidden morality system to sniper
elites gameplay completely changed the
way I played I would spend time tagging
every soldier reading their Intel seeing
how they interacted with other soldiers
and then would slowly untag anyone who I
deemed worthy of keeping their brains
inside of their skulls I became a sort
of judge jury and executioner staying
the executions based on the merits of a
small but impactful piece of Intel I
would choose which lives are taken which
to spare then adapt my path through the
levels so I could avoid the medic that
helps out at enemy soldier while going
out of my way to snuff out the soldier
that opened fire on innocent civilians
instead of mercilessly gunning down
every foe I sought and taking off
objectives I created a new role-playing
wrinkle why punish the bad eggs and the
enemy ranks while sparing the soldiers
who seemed like good people stuck in bad
situations if you're playing Sniper
Elite 4 I recommend revisiting a mission
with this in mind let the Intel you find
make a case of the salvation or
damnation of the people on the other end
of your scope don't give in to the
temptation to kill everyone no matter
how much the game invites you to indulge
your bloodless or how exhilarating it
may be to find that round and see it fly
through a stranger's cerebellum so
remember how I asked you to take note
that shot at the start of the video
looking at the character's history do
you think he deserved it thanks so much
for watching this video about sniper
elites for hidden morality system it
became more than a gory sniper simulator
for me and I would love to hear your
thoughts whether you agree with me or
not I encourage you to try out yourself
if you've enjoyed this video please
remember to hit that like button
subscribe for more features like this
and I'll see you next time